so maybe everything is uh okay maybe
it's not I don't know over the past
weekend we saw two of the biggest
banking collapses in U.S history with
Silicon Valley Bank and Signature Bank
that is the second largest collapse in
history followed only a few days later
by the third largest collapse in U.S
history 100 billion dollars from their
these Banks market caps have been wiped
out we saw a massive wave of trading
halts in the stock market and it's not
uh not to confidence building especially
when Joe Biden for once wakes up at 9am
to talk to the American people about
just what's going on saying don't worry
everything's under control of course now
most people don't think anything is
under control and it's actually causing
a lot of fear so we'll talk about that
plus we got a bunch of other stories too
we made a bit of news on Friday I guess
because Steve Bannon criticized Elon
Musk and then every Outlet in the world
decided to write it up then Matt Gates
took a clip of it and then Elon Musk
himself essentially just called Steve
Bannon not smart and evil we'll talk
about that plus a whole bunch of other
weird things like I don't know some
giant rocking space is going to fly past
the Earth so the apocalypse may be
coming sooner than we think and then
you've got
h5n1 fears because apparently bird flu
has been wiping out chickens and there's
concern over whether or not it's now
transferring to mammals which it is and
this has a 60 mortality rate so with uh
all the news about the apocalypse we got
a lot to talk about but before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com click that join us button
and become a member to support our work
directly and you will get access to
exclusive segments from the timcast IRL
podcast live from at about 10 10 pm when
we wrap up the live show we then record
live an uncensored members only show now
if you don't want to watch it live you
don't have to you can come and watch it
anytime you want it will be archived on
the website in a huge library of content
and with the way things are going we
could really use your support as members
so if anything if you just like watching
this show and like what we do become a
member because it is quite literally How
We Do do it and if people don't become
members that eventually we don't do it
so if you want us to keep doing it
become a member support our work and
support our cultural Endeavors don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and in light of the
fact that we are talking about all of
these different apocalyptic scenarios we
are being joined by Drew Miller of
fortitude Ranch thanks Tim it's great to
be on the show you want to pull up that
microphone sure uh and uh and who are
you and what is 42 wrench uh I'm CEO of
Fortune Rancho recreational and survival
community and whether it's a banking
collapse a civil war an asteroid hitting
the Earth and causing crop failures over
the next several years are what I'm
really worried about in h5n1 human
transmissible form of bird flu our
members including yourself will be able
to survive it by coming to one of our
facilities in rural areas and riding out
the collapse and aside from that if
you're not a prepper it's just a fun
place to hang out yep we're a
recreational facility too that's right
enjoy the good times
it's good stuff well we got a lot to
talk about too especially with uh with
your experience with all of this stuff
so they should get interesting thanks
for hanging out thank you we also got
Phil Labonte Chillin hello I am
filibonti anti-communist encounter
revolutionary
oh and I'm Ian croslin probably the
opposite of that no no I'm not I'm just
kidding I'm not a communist Joe and I
drove we drove to Congress the other
night there and back and we had some
deep conversations about philosophy and
spirituality I think Phil and I are like
two heads of a coin whereas he's the
philosopher I'm the spiritual
spiritualist but uh it was pretty fun
conversation trying to trying to
identify God Through Math I I thoroughly
enjoyed hanging out with you unions it
was a good time what's up Drew I see you
got uh you got cards you're gonna be
showing us yeah I think those will come
up later on the slides slides all right
well let's move this along Serge yo
what's up uh hopefully the audio works
this time huh guys well in studio seems
uh seems to be fun you want to pop the
window open and then jump into the first
story all right ladies and gentlemen we
got the story from timcast.com President
Joe Biden tells Americans to have
confidence in banking system as
additional Banks fail Silicon Valley
Banks and signature Banks were both
taken over by the federal government
amid collapsing share prices I also want
to point out that for some of the uh
images we use on timcast.com they're AI
generated just look at how horrifying
this is like this picture of bank run
has these people screaming but it's like
the jinji Ido of of bank run AI
generated images it looks like these
people are being hunted down by some
Demon that's stealing their soul as the
uh Banks collapse but anyway I thought
that was funny
the federal government took control of
Silicon Valley Banks a top Bank in the
tech sector on March 10th after its
share price Plum rapidly plummeted New
York Regulators announced on March 12th
that they have taken control of
Signature Bank known known for Real
Estate lending and serving clients tied
to the crypto currency industry quote
the bottom line is this Americans can
rest assured that our banking system is
safe your deposits are safe Biden said
during a press conference at the White
House on March 13th let me also assure
you we will not stop at this we'll do
whatever is needed oh boy
I love how when uh East Palestine has
this massive chemical spill he doesn't
even show up he didn't even mention it
okay he mentioned it don't get me wrong
but there's no bailouts they don't care
about the people who live there but when
Millionaires and billionaires in Silicon
Valley have their woke Tech sector
threatened he comes out on TV and says
at nine in the morning of all times Joe
Biden waking up at 9am saying we're
going to take care of this nothing to
worry about here's what I think
I hate
I hate to go on a show with as many
viewers as this and be like the end is
nigh or something like that
but
Joe Biden has to come out and say this
he has to because if he doesn't there's
a run on the banks and if people go on
TV and say anything other than
everything is A-Okay then there's a run
of the banks so that's the default
position of every personality and media
whether it's true or not I don't know is
to come out and pretend like
everything's going to be fine yeah it
doesn't make any sense because your
bank's insure for 250 000 per account so
99 of Americans Banks can fail FDIC
they're insured you have nothing to lose
so it's amazing to me that Biden is
panicking and doing the stuff for the
ultra Rich you have more than 250 000
first so for Silicon Valley Bank he's
just helping out big tech companies and
Rich investors in big tech companies
because normal people who had deposits
at Silicon Valley Bank have nothing to
worry about most people don't have 250
000 sitting in a checking or a bank
account they had nothing to lose yep and
so they're going to be doing is
apparently the FDIC c will cover
deposits above 250k and apparently I
guess BuzzFeed had all their money in
Silicon Valley Bank well now I'm really
encouraging no bailouts okay uh bye-bye
they shouldn't it doesn't benefit us it
hurts the normal people because that
means Federal government's bailing it
out that means more debt that means more
inflation that everyone including poor
people will pay and this is just a move
to help rich people who have more than
250 000 in big companies and Banks it
makes no sense to be doing this well
there were like I was listening to a
space today most of the day I was
listening to spaces and just trying to
wrap my head around what's going on and
from what I can gather is the biggest
worry is Contagion to other Banks so
we've got two of the biggest bank
failures in in American history
happening over the course of the past
weekend I
I am of the opinion that if if the
government's the government's going to
bail uh bail everyone out or the bail
the banks out because the government has
basically taken responsibility for any
any failures in in the banking industry
uh you know they've bailed out
everybody every time that there's been
any kind of well any kind of the rich
Elites
no I mean to be fair they did they did
do all they they printed a lot of money
and whenever the government prints money
and it goes to the people it ends up
with the big Banks and the big
corporations anyways because everyone
gets that money and they spend it it's
not like people go and they sit on it
when they get if you get 500 bucks from
the government if the government when
the government you know was passing out
cash people didn't sit on that and it
was enough money to change anyone's life
from or that they make it you know that
they're going to invest with it anyways
so that money just ends up in the big
corporations hands anyways because
people spend it so it's just it's
they're just going to continue to print
money because that's what they have to
do so when they get together again when
the FED gets together again instead of
doing 50 basis points it's likely
they're going to do 25 it's possible
they're gonna do zero and then they'll
see what happens I don't know what's
gonna happen between now and then
obviously but they're gonna take the
break off of the off the raising of
rates because they can't have the rate I
can't keep uh interest rates uh keep
raising interest rates the way that they
are with this kind of this kind of
monetary situation in the U.S where they
want to provoke loans to the banks
basically so the Bannon asked me on
Friday Steve Bannon why it's a Ponzi
scheme this economic system that we're
in and I I gave him like a half answer I
said that it's because we're borrowing
money from our banks our institutions
our government is borrowing money from
the Federal Reserve and then promising
to pay them back with interest the only
way to get that interest is to borrow
more money from them at interest to pay
back the interest which now we owe
interest on the new borrow so we have to
borrow more to pay back the interest on
the edge and uh the real Ponzi is when
what happens is that money goes to the
banks then the banks loan out to the
common American to for mortgages and
then they have to pay the interest they
push the interest down to the small guy
sort of and so all this whole system is
banked off these 40-year interest
payments by American people constantly
paying more than they borrowed to fund
this Federal Reserve usury well I mean
it's it's it's sort of to fund that but
remember like when you are getting a
mortgage you're buying that you're
getting a house too so it's not you pay
the debt it's technically owned by the
bank until you pay them back well yeah
but you get to live in the house it's
not a one-sided operation is what I'm
saying like I understand what you're
saying that it's frustrating that you
have to pay uh pay more than the than
what you're borrowing but that's why the
banks are in business so that way like
they'll lend you the money you pay them
more than they actually lended you
that's the business model and let's
let's let's let's let's talk about it uh
seriously a lot of people they don't
like International war and things like
that a lot of people they don't like the
Petro dollar they don't like imperialism
they don't like big bank bailouts but I
I believe for the most part not
completely but for the most part these
are the evil things that these evil
people do that does have a positive
effect for a lot of people in this
country that is when the US Military is
setting up military bases in foreign
countries and pointing guns at people
and saying use the US dollar or else it
creates demand for our currency and then
we don't have to do as much work and if
the Petro dollar collapses then we're
gonna have to go back to chopping wood
and raising chickens on our own and
actually producing things in our country
something most Americans aren't prepared
for and don't want to do most Americans
that are young now they're just
demanding free mini free stuff
Ken clippenstein today was tweeting
about about uh
forgiving student loans like today
because they're talking about bailing
out Banks the banks that if you bail out
a bank you're bailing out a bank because
people had money that they put into the
bank so that's completely totally
isolated from like the the situation
with student loans where people didn't
have money they borrowed money they got
an education ostensibly and then then
they're asking to be forgiven for that
for that borrowing money well you're the
one you're you're getting the
forgiveness for the education or for the
bar
it's the excessive compounding interest
that is the problem they used to call it
that's fine but that's not the same
thing as forgiving the loan in totality
correct that's different yeah I don't
know I'll hardly ever advocate for just
deleting people's loans I think that's
kind of dumb but like the idea the
profiting mechanism of loaning money I
get it it was a risk if I loan you a
hundred bucks there's a risk you'll
never show up again so I've got at least
like give me 110 back that way if I loan
out 10 times and one of those guys walks
away at least I made my money back but
it's excessive compounding interest debt
upon debt is like it's easy it's almost
incapable by the common American mind it
is the the issue here is how our whole
economy is one big Ponzi scheme from the
get-go that is unsustainable and going
back to 2008 we can clearly see there's
holes in the system they put a Band-Aid
over those holes but the water is
spraying through the ship is sinking and
now we're seeing it's it's like that
cartoon where the holes are popping up
in the hole in the cartoon characters
putting his fingers and his toes and his
eye or whatever you're not going to stop
it I'm but here's what I want to say
bailouts okay if you want to sit in your
lounge chair and watch sports and Order
nachos and drink beer and not have to
worry about anything you want the
bailouts you want it all if you are an
entitled gen Z or gen Zer or Millennial
who wants to wants to go to college for
gender studies you want the bailouts and
this is why you are seeing the default
liberal and left us be alike we need to
make sure we take care of this because
then they prop up the system that allows
them to do nothing me I kind of think we
need to go back to a little bit of hard
work I'm not saying everybody should go
work on ranches where they tend to
chickens and goats and stuff like that
but maybe just a little bit because
right now we got a bunch of like that
viral video of the Gen zero being like
why do I have to work to live that is
burned into my into my brain and it
makes it work it's just let the banks
fail then they can go be like I'm hungry
like well start picking food yourself
it's grow your own food and check
chickens or whatever
Biden says that no none of these losses
will be borne by the taxpayer for them
he tweeted that seven hours ago for the
record yeah he said we'll pay for it
from the fees the banks pay into the
deposit Insurance Fund now I understand
wanting to bail out 250 000 of uninsured
a lot a lot of 95 of the accounts in
this Silicon Valley Bank thing were not
insured so all those 250 000 accounts
are gone but they're decided to bail
them out I understand bailing out the
small investor or companies up to 250
000 correct no again if you had 250 you
had less than 250 000 in that bank or
any Bank you have no risk you're covered
they all are not uh yeah they all are
the only ones who are getting bailout
are the ones who are Beyond 250 000 so
there were big tech companies that this
Bank invested in and people invested
money in these companies and the spank
did too so we're bailing out a bank
because they're huge big payoffs didn't
work for them and they failed and it's
back just like we did in 2008 we
invested in tons of taxpayers money to
bail out Wall Street firms who had huge
Investments and derivatives making
billions of dollars of profits for the
people working in those Wall Street
Banks of zero value to American citizens
but you know Goldman Sachs the the
treasurer of Secretary of Treasury that
time so former Goldman Sachs CEO and
Federal Reserve people Goldman Sachs and
other Wall Street firms and the
government and the Federal Reserve full
of people from Wall Street bailed out
Wall Street at the expense of the rest
of the citizens you know the too big to
fail argument and that's what's going on
here the same way only in this case
you're bailing out banks that did bad
investments in tech companies and tech
companies that make big donations to
people from both political parties
that's who's getting bailed out this is
not to help you know low-income people
with 250 000 you know bank money in
there this is just people at the bank
making big Investments that are getting
bailed out from this unless citizens
let's talk about bad Investments
BuzzFeed says most of most of cash and
cash equivalents held at svb
this is from Yahoo finance BuzzFeed Inc
Reuters actually said on Monday that
most of its cash and equivalents were
held at Silicon Valley Bank which was
shut down startup Focus under svb last
week failed shares and BuzzFeed were
down 8.6 at 1.17 in extended trading
Monday wow that's really bad Silver
Linings it's like well I mean like it's
down eight percent which is really bad
but they're only at a dollar Seventeen
per share anyway which is just really
bad the company which has been grappling
with a tough advertising Market amid
concerns over a slowing economy also
reported a 27 decline in ad Revenue to
50 million dollars in the quarter ending
December 31st it expects first quarter
overall overall Revenue to range from 61
million to 67 million they reported a
revenue of 91.6 million for the same
period that last year uh let svb fail
because
um you know I'm gonna try to be a dick
but then BuzzFeed goes with it so but I
guess what some people in the Super Chat
are saying is that even with FDIC
insurance it's going to take months
before depositors can start getting
access to their funding so that means
even uh one of the craziest stories I
saw because we someone mentioned this uh
last week
Etsy sellers didn't get paid
now my understanding is if you're a
seller on Etsy you like I make a you
know a doily or something and then
someone buys it and they use this
Marketplace and then I send it out
but the fact is the people bought a
product Etsy held the money and the Etsy
sellers didn't get paid that's crazy
that's what happens and then what may
happen is even with the the they're
doing the national Deposit Bank from the
FDIC for these companies buzzfeed's
funds might be jammed up and their
employees might not get paid this this
is is going literally to have a ripple
effect now I also want to address this
real this thing real quick too
BuzzFeed saying that they're uh their
revenues are dropping due to a tough
advertising Market I can confirm that is
a fact because I've talked about it here
so take this into consideration with the
with the banking industry getting hit
this bad I can also tell you like our
revenue is down not to the point where
I'm crying about it or anything because
we do well enough but that's why I'm
like hey everybody become a member so
that we can continue paying our staff
and continue funding these projects and
everything like that uh because the the
market seems like it's headed towards a
very very serious downturn it's
interesting because buzzfeed's reporting
their ad revenue is down is projected to
be 61 to 67 million down from 91. that's
basically what I was saying like 40 30
to 40 drop off
but that right now should be increasing
not decreasing which suggests this year
is going to get really really bad for
media and when media gets hit it's
because the base of the economy the
Grassroots already got hit so what this
is we're effectively a canary in a coal
mine when small mom and pop shops Stop
their 100 budget per month for their
little grocery store or Diner and then
we it all like let's say this a hundred
thousand small businesses across the
country just hypothetically
that are buying a small amount of
advertising it all trickles up into a
handful of small media personalities who
then all yell are Revenue dropped
dramatically basically telling you that
at the individual granular level
revenues are dropping and spending is
dropping which means the next step is
going to be serious economic downturn
with the banks collapsing with the with
BuzzFeed even complaining about it not
that I care if BuzzFeed collapses to be
completely honest it would suck if
people lost their jobs but I don't know
if these are Jobs worth saving that
being said it will have a contagious
ripple effect so the question is
how do you feel about the current state
of things because I got to be honest I
have absolutely maybe maybe I don't want
to pull Bill Maher here but I personally
have no problem myself with having to go
and chop wood and then forage for food
literally we ate chives fresh off the
ground we go out in the backyard we grab
chives out of the ground and eat them
they're delicious we have chickens I'd
have absolutely no problem going to a
place like fortitude Ranch rolling up my
sleeves and taking care of animals that
being said I don't know if you all do
and that and then people have kids and
people have medical conditions people
with diabetes especially need access to
these things if you like the level of
comfort we have you probably want the
government to bail out all these all
these people
everyone that just like you said
everyone that enjoys a a modern
lifestyle at the end of the day you do
want the banks to be bailed out as much
as everyone's going to say they don't
you have to be prepared for
early 20th century lifestyle
if the banks fail I mean fair enough I
mean but it's like if you don't know how
to do things and you don't have a place
to go and you don't have some savings
and some food and some stuff handled
things are going to be really horrible
for you like I mean the estimates that
you hear after the first year it's
something like ten percent if if the U.S
like the dollar collapsed something like
10 of the population will make it or
something ridiculously small it's not it
it's not something that anyone should be
hoping let me read this
I want to read the Super Chat real quick
Olivia Claire says I'm a Etsy seller I
should be getting paid today for last
week's sales it said it won't transfer
until tomorrow I rely on Etsy as my main
income at the moment really scary time
as a seller and sellers shouldn't have
their money being withheld by I mean
you're the person selling yeah but SV
bees money's jammed up so let's see if
they move in quick enough and if they
don't the crazy thing is if the
individual can't get their money let's
say it takes three months that means
they're not buying cheeseburgers that
means local Mom and Pop Pop Shop Diner
they're not selling cheeseburgers they
ain't buying ads they're not paying
their employees their employees ain't
buying cheeseburgers and it Cycles
through and ripples through yeah but you
just can't have this continue you can't
keep bailing out firms and they make bad
Investments and derivatives and spend
billions and waste it and then we bail
them out and lsvp has made bad Tech
Investments they've lost money now we're
bailing you can't do that forever
ultimately people have to pay for that
and the debt keeps going up inflation's
going up and you reach a point where you
can't do it and you just encourage more
of this bad investment when you bail
people out it's called the moral hazard
problem it's exactly what we're doing
when we keep bailing out and again we're
not bailing out you know small in count
people they will be protected they will
be repaid we're bailing out big tech
companies with SVP just like we build up
big Wall Street firms it's worse than
that it's bailing out wokeness
specifically
here's my here's my belief if you take a
look at at Silicon Valley Bank's mission
statement stuff boy did they invest a
lot in diversity Equity occlusion and
access they call it
d-e-i-a they put an extra a at the end
of there and uh and the apparently their
risk Chief risk officer was like laid
off and they didn't refill the position
but they did hire an lgbtq advocate for
seminars and so everyone's like what was
your priority why would that be a
surprise to anybody that a Silicon
Valley Bank prioritized their religion
over the function of their business this
is it's what they do right so here's
what I think I'm willing to bet that svb
started investing in companies based on
wokeness and not Merit so they would go
to a company and be like okay so you're
a tech company what do you do we have an
app what does your app do uh it's a it's
a texting app how will it make money we
have a really diverse team of people who
work here really how much money do you
need uh five
50 million 50 million and you said you
preach diversity that's right great
here's the money our app is so diverse
it lets black people find black
businesses it's the most racist app on
the planet no it's for white people that
can find white owned business like the
most that's right what they do it's not
diverse segregative and racist like when
they made black panther they're like
this movie's very diverse and it's like
the cast was 95 black that's not diverse
diversity will focus exclusively on One
race of people but who who in the
audience would disagree with me one if
you disagree 20 if you agree that svb
was likely investing in companies based
on diversity and not based on the
function of their business they were
pretty open about it I haven't been able
to look at the books but they said as
such on their website yeah they had an a
rating with es a ESG score yeah my my
I'm gonna tell you this I don't want to
give anybody advice but I
I'm I'm thinking about investing my my
money in stocks from companies that have
the lowest possible ESG score oh yeah
and getting all of my money out of
anything with a high ESG score you sound
like Vivek Rama Swami is that what he
said I don't know if he said those
exactly it's all about investing your
money in non-esg right now well it's
it's I think it's I think that sounds
right if a company is is focusing their
efforts on environmental social
governance that is not a functioning
business everything that's for if you're
focusing on social issues and right now
essentially what what happens is ESG is
social issues being shoved into into
businesses and bureaucracies and stuff
like that you see the social issues in
in uh
in schools and stuff and that's part of
why test scores are so are going go down
every year you spend more money every
year and test scores keep going down
every year it it it's essentially
supplanting the purpose for every single
thing that it touches so if it's schools
it it's it it corrupts them and they and
you and it stops you stop churning out
kids that know anything there's a
There's a comic from Stone toss I know
the left really hates Stone toss but
it's an advertising agency and then the
the advertising guy is Market is is he's
got a burger restaurant clients and he's
like here's our proposed ad campaign and
it's a white person and a black person
making out and then the guy's like how
is this going to sell cheeseburgers and
the guy goes cheeseburgers but that
that's a really good example of what
this is the same reason why FTX failed
the uh the crypto thing
yeah obsessively ESG Sam bankman freed
would talk about it I think there's more
to it than that look man yeah he's a big
into investing in climate change there's
video of him being like we're gonna fix
the world with impact investment use
different words but that's the that was
the purpose well bitcoin's doing really
well spend your money on what there's
there's an argument I've heard people
making or people talking today that this
they there are people that believe that
this is actually going to be a
decoupling event so the re the reason
that Bitcoin and the markets responded
positively once the once Biden started
talking I guess is because everyone
essentially is super the Market's
assumed that there was going to be a
slowing to the raising of interest rates
and so people are like well we can you
know get cheap money or make you know
get continue to invest in in uh in
things and stuff you know the biggest
crime that's I see out of this whole
thing with this svb is the execs five
Executives paid them they sold stock
within the two months leading up to the
the crumble uh for Millions I think
every every executive made over a
million the CEO making 2.3 million or
something uh roughly maybe somebody made
under and they also so apparently paid
out a big bonus to a bunch of employees
on Friday right before the announcement
that's a crime that is that is
absolutely that investigate that
investigate those Executives take that
money back pay back the people that lost
money with that yeah
that's not going to happen again back in
2008 when they did this they did the
same thing they weren't just bailing out
the Wall Street firms like the the
Federal Reserve and the treasury
Department they basically negotiated the
sale of Merrill Lynch to Bank of America
part of the deal was millions of dollars
in bonuses to these Merrill Lynch execs
so they wouldn't leave the company and
they could get the deal done just you
couldn't list all the illegal things
going on negotiated by a Federal Reserve
U.S treasury Department officials many
of them former golden and Sachs
employees they did it openly they got
millions and nothing was it was approved
it was your taxpayer dollars helped
finance that this is so it's happened
before it's going to keep on happening
it's the norm this is Biden tweeted this
out eight hours ago the management of
both these banks will be fired if a bank
taken over by the FDIC the people
running if the bank is taken over by the
FDC the people running that bank
shouldn't work there anymore
he doesn't talk about the the stock that
they sold of the of the defunct company
right before the company and it was
announced that it was defunct I mean the
five execs selling stock in the two
months leading up to the collapse is an
indication that they knew there was a
collapse coming which that deserves an
investigation in my opinion
um Biden says they're all going to be
fired all the Management's going to be
fired and that
the people running the bank shouldn't
work there anymore those are his words
Joe Biden doesn't know what should
happen with a bank Joe the president is
in no position to make a call about what
should or should not happen with a bank
if you want to have investigations or
something fine but Joe Biden is in no
position to be making calls about a bank
at all I don't trust Joe Biden's calls
about basically anything the man is
barely con barely has contact with
reality so Joe Biden's opinion on Banks
and who should run a bank is the least
interesting thing in the world this
string of tweets that he wrote this
under on the uh on Friday the FDIC
threat obviously was not written by him
no it sounds like some Economist using
his I mean it's different than other
tweets that he puts out like last week
the whole Like This Time It's Different
period this time you know those crappy
tweets he puts out uh this is obviously
some sort of Economist explaining their
their procedure but they're saying
they're going to fire the uh the execs
the management I don't what would be the
ethical thing to do for this 10 12 13
million in stock that they all sold
like they're the executives of the
company they lost a lot of people a lot
of money
I don't know I I'm I'm not 100 sure like
I don't know who actually is being
affected most mostly like who's really
being negatively affected
um I don't know I know that the the uh
svb was mostly crypto companies and and
they funded a lot of startups and stuff
like that so I don't know that there's a
lot of small investors that are small
Bankers you know small uh whatever you
call it uh at the uh that they that they
cater to so you know I don't know
exactly what what should be done and I I
don't even know that we should be making
decisions yet because it just happened
today to talk about you got you kind of
want to see what what the actual
repercussions are going to be how it's
going to go through the economy the fog
of war is the position and they're
moving so quickly in the fog of War
acting like they know what's happening
and people are just like I don't know so
I can't say no I don't have any pushback
right now because I don't know the facts
and people are scared so they're moving
quickly I want to pull up this uh this
tweet here and just really quickly point
out that
someone removed one of the plugs from
the cameras and it's not in the room so
we're just like like Phil's camera died
but they're all plugged I'm like wait
what and then we looked and it's just
gone the plug was just stolen by
somebody Cable's gone is it a uh should
be okay HDMI oh it's bad no no the power
cable like the plug for the camera is
just gone yeah it's a little Hammerhead
eight but it's okay we figured it out
because we got mad skills but anyway
let's talk about the story here we got
this from the kobasi letter
the two-year treasury yield is now on
track for one of its biggest two-day
drops in history the yield is down over
100 basis points from its high last week
Bond markets are moving quicker than
what we saw in 2008 bonds think the
system just collapsed
I certainly hope not but uh in the event
that they do I suppose the question is
what happens if the market actually does
collapse and this assessment is correct
if all of a sudden you wake up in the
morning your bank is telling you hey you
can't take money out just yet hey we're
not so sure what's going to happen or
outright this ripples through all these
other Banks I got to tell you I looked
at a bunch of Bank stocks I looked at
the stocks for some of the banks that we
use and they're all very very very down
and that's kind of worrying so uh Drew
what happened investors and Bank stocks
need to be worried which is largely
wealthy people you know big funds well
but whatever citizens aren't going to
lose from this and again your deposits
are insured well no no no no no no
it's these bailouts money going into
that I get that cost you but I mean if
if the big companies go under and we do
see a Great Recession like event or this
is worse than 2008 then what does that
mean for the average person in terms of
their ability to get a job their ability
to find food or what
well I don't think I think the 2008
thread in this threat to the average
citizens and average banks are grossly
exaggerated I mean if you're a small
Bank a normal Bank you're not affected
by things going on in Wall Street you're
not investing derivatives or high-tech
companies your Banks aren't going to
fail because you don't have investments
in that your Investments earn mortgages
traditional stuff signature banks will
not fail yeah but what kind of real
estate commercial real estate big bold
Investments and and bad bets so that the
investors in that bank they should lose
their money the bank should fail and
citizens shouldn't bail it out because
when they bail it out now I'm being
punished everyone across the U.S gets
punished when the US government steps in
and bails someone else we will pay for
that you think the real risk to the
Americans is if they do the ballots not
if they ignore it correct so wait if
they do the bails then people are going
to lose money and and you know because
our debt keeps going up inflation keeps
going up and sooner or later you got to
pay for that and it's going to hurt the
economy it's been hurting us you know
already we're likely to have a recession
we've been in recession threat mode for
a long time why because the federal
government gave away trillions of
dollars unnecessarily during covid you
cannot give money away sooner or later
you got to pay the price the price is
we're going to go into a recession and
we're going to have horrible inflation
we're paying the price so every time you
bail out a big Silicon Valley Bank or a
Wall Street big firm which you wouldn't
do for a mid-size or small company or
Bank whenever you bail them out citizens
everywhere else not just in the US but
around the world since we've got the
dollar they pay for that and it
shouldn't happen so then it sounds like
let's just let them fall they should I
mean Bannon was saying that on Friday
you know he was telling Matt Gates and
Dan Bishop on this show resist do not
let them convince you to bail these
people out let you know but I wonder I
mean if in 2008 they didn't bail out any
banks what do you think would have
happened uh well no one really knows but
I don't think it would have been a
disaster even disaster if the Wall
Street firms but who cares I mean if
Goldman Sachs and Merrill Lynch you name
all those firms that they went under who
did they lend to huge Fortune 500
companies who pay outlandish fees and
they're not the only ones who can do
investment banking their Investment
Banking firms small ones all over the US
who can step in and take their place
they should have had trillions of
dollars of losses and derivatives let
them take their losses 98 percent of
Americans don't invest in derivatives
they don't invest in these high-tech
companies so we won't suffer we have
some comments here people are saying
you're wrong there's a video of the FDIC
saying they only have funds to cover
around four percent of the losses and
the risk is real someone else said that
the FDA FDIC has only enough to ensure
about one percent of the deposits and
this will be a push to get us into
cbdc I don't know what that is Central
Bank digital currency oh yeah yeah okay
okay
FDIC that is something the government's
own there to bail them out so if we want
to bail out the FDIC for the 2500
thousand dollar deposits that's okay I
didn't want to bail out for the
investment beyond the 250 000. that's
the bigger Bill we can't afford you know
one issue is Bank consolidation in 2008
465 banks failed a bunch of them were
maybe all of them were bought up it was
like Wells Fargo we came out with like
four big Banks I could see another same
with the Great Depression that was a big
wealth consolidation you know they
bankrupt everyone they buy up the assets
it's always well I mean and
I I just want to push back a little bit
on the idea that they bankrupt like it's
not intentional like it's not like there
are people pulling the strings that are
trying to bankrupt other people so they
can buy up the assets or at least not
not all the time I know that has
happened in history but still the point
being like that the consolidation
happens because if you have a lot of
money and you and and everybody loses
money you still have a lot of money so
there's a bunch of opportunities to buy
stuff up that's what happens anytime
anytime there's any kind of financial
crisis or whatever rich people get
richer because they have funds to make
to capitalize on the marginal businesses
going under let me ask you guys a
question though so uh Tim Cass
Corporation has more than 250 000 and
that's the only amount that's insured
what if our bank went under everybody
here would be out of a job how would
people here feel about that you got to
be able to make money if if we're not
making money uh we deserve to fail if
we're not in the block because if we go
if the bank froze our money right now
there would be no paychecks for any one
of the employees the company of course
makes money but the money in the bank
that we need to pay the employees until
revenue is comes in because it comes in
doesn't come we don't just have money
our our customers our members they will
you know pay 10 bucks advertisers will
pay a monthly thing or once a month for
those three to four weeks if we have no
money what happens we just tell all of
our employees don't worry about it we
tell our our our utilities so this is
the question when I'm looking at these
tweets about people lining upside of
Silicon Valley Bank and you you show up
one down people to think about this you
show up to your bank because you're a
regular working class person and they're
like you have no money you say how do I
pay my rent you're a small business who
maybe isn't even one of these big woke
tech companies or whatever and you've
got a million bucks and you need and and
you're a business that you know you got
a decent profit margin let's say you're
doing 10 20 per month you spend 5 500
000 you make say six hundred thousand
that money goes into emergency rainy day
funds potential Investments then you
have your employees that are the bulk of
those costs and then one day your
paychecks bounce the bank says there's
no funds what do you do you should have
five bank accounts first so you have
1.25 million insured by FDIC uh per the
size of your bank you should probably
have a Time the five numbers great you
know five's not good enough if you're
like if you're Facebook you know no
five's not good enough for Facebook but
for small businesses you should have
multiple bank accounts a lot of people
having issues couldn't get their money
out because they didn't have anywhere
else to put it so they're like Mad Dash
to open a second bank account like have
multiple business accounts secondly I
think yeah if your company can't pay the
people the people aren't going to get
paid that's the deal get ready to live
without money for four months or three
two weeks or whatever I want to say
some some uh some words just before I
make the statement
Max Kaiser and Stacy Herbert
because
I was thinking today we were talking if
we had a part of our balance sheet in
Bitcoin
Bitcoin went up and Bitcoin has a
different stability and a lot of
companies transferred some of their
balance sheet into Bitcoin and so if we
were like some we use primarily USD for
all our liquid transactions but then we
store some of the value in Bitcoin and
actually pay some employees in Bitcoin
all those employees that money they get
in Bitcoin is worth substantially more
right now than it would have been when
they received it so I'm thinking like I
don't know if the intention with all
this collapse is to push us into like
like some that person was saying Central
Bank digital currencies or something
like that but it certainly has me
looking at my crypto being like it's up
it does have the intention of Bank
consolidation
um centralization of currency and then
um I think they're going to want to try
and track it so well they I mean they're
going to be any kind of if you use a
cbdc they automatically can track it any
kind of critical yup everything you do
any digital currency like that it's
automatically tracked they can turn your
money off they can tell you what you are
and are not allowed to buy that's
complete your money is completely
programmable but if that's the direction
of the water flow then maybe no no
crypto I mean don't ignore it no crypto
is one thing Bitcoin is different and a
cbdc is a third yeah cbdc doesn't have
to be on a block I just wanna I just
want to point out the rumors going
around and I don't know if this is true
is that Harry and Megan had their money
in svb I heard that and I don't know if
that's true but everyone's laughing
being like all their money's gone or
whatever either way it's probably a
scary weekend because even with Joe
Biden coming out being like don't worry
we're gonna pay everybody and get access
to their deposits or whatever how long
do you have to wait and where is the
money
again the message should be you don't
have to worry if you've got less than
250 000 there's no need to do a run on
the bank that should be no for sure the
message shouldn't be no matter how much
money you've invested or how badly the
government will bail you out that you
cannot afford to do all that they do is
tell these big Banks keep playing with
the money like jerks because they're too
big to fail they say and say it's it's
not coming from the taxpayer but here's
what Joe Biden's not telling you
the money paid to to the fdi's the
premiums paid for FDIC insurance is
intended for you the little guy not for
the Millionaires and the billionaires
and now what they're saying is your
rainy day fund is being given to the
Millionaires and the billionaires sound
like Bernie Sanders over here the
Millionaires and the billionaires are
getting your FDIC money from five cents
knuckle historically the FDIC pays
insured deposits within a few days after
a bank closes uh usually the next
business day and what they'll do is
they'll open a new account at another
insured bank and then send you the money
that way uh someone had mentioned that
it might take a couple months earlier
but I think they moved pretty quick
hopefully if that's true then yeah I
think the small guy doesn't have
anything to worry about well here's a
short post from Amy Curtis on Twitter
that I saw it said here's why the
government is going to bail out sbv but
won't send disaster Aid to Ohio and you
can see an image showing California as
very blue well you can't really see it
because the way it's cropped on screen
there you go and then you have this
image which is Ohio being like all red
and East Palestine and being you know
over here in the Eastern Ohio so a lot
of this does absolutely feel like a
combination of elitism and partisanship
the fact that Joe Biden got up at nine
in the morning first thing and said your
money is safe but when a train exploded
spraying toxic chemicals they burn and
toxic chemicals are everywhere it's
getting in the water fish are dying the
governor says a plume of chemicals is
Flowing down the river into West
Virginia nowhere to be found it tells
you who Butters their bread who they're
serving and who they're concerned about
of course when I look at things like
this and then we had that Jane Fonda
thing you guys see the Jane Fonda thing
last week Hanoi Jane talking she said on
The View
that she was asked we have to fight for
pro you know for pro-choice whatever and
then Joy behero was like well short of
protesting and voting what do we do and
she said murder and then someone was
like wait what are you saying she goes
murder and they went huh no she's joking
so the way I see it is all signs are
indicative of systemic collapse whether
the bond market is correct or not in the
previous segment that it's going to
collapse whether the banking thing two
of the biggest collapse in history
happening back to back
and they they're they're seeming like
one's in California one's in New York
are they are they related all I got to
tell you is hyperpolarization
hyperinflation maybe not hyperinflation
but the inflation's ridiculously high
now banking collapses and people on TV
saying psychotic extremist things
how is is Drew you're the expert I guess
or you're the one selling a product do
you think we're on the verge of some
kind of major collapse and should people
I don't want to say be worried but
should they be prepared I think a
recession is likely I don't think a
banking collapse is coming but what
about I mean beyond that I mean when
you're looking at the weaponization of
government when you're looking at people
on TV calling for murder whether it's a
joke or not we're seeing violence in the
streets we're seeing 150 far leftists
storm a government facility in Georgia
and burn it up then you've got the
January 6th stuff where they're saying
the FBI was destroying evidence it
doesn't feel like this system whether
it's Financial or political exists
anymore it seems more like a smoldering
pit well we track 50 we call them
threats or trigger events that could
lead to a collapse but you're only
talking about one of them and that's you
know something like a financial collapse
or something that really triggers a
civil war there's a banking collapse
that doesn't mean there's loss of Law
and Order but if people start doing
civil unrest and law enforcement goes
then you've got a cloud perhaps where
you worry about the things we worry
about which is people going out looting
stealing killing and it's not safe to
live here I mean that's just one of 50
events we have we have more things to
worry about than that I think that are
more likely to get us what like what
what do you got like avian flu is the
one that I'm very concerned about right
now our electric grid is probably my
number two biggest concern the fragility
electric I think that's likely to kill
us off before uh you know collapse from
a banking collapse I've got a bunch of
stuff on the bird flu let's talk about
the electric grid first what what about
the grid has you worried it's been
vulnerable and we've known about it for
decades and the government has done
nothing to fix it it's vulnerable not
just from the physical you know
terrorist attacks you've heard about in
recent months it's vulnerable from
natural causes solar flares
electromagnetic pulse from a solar flare
can take down the Grid it's done it
before the reason why I said we'll talk
about this one first is because you've
heard the stories that are going around
where extremists are attacking
substations it's not the first time they
did an attack on the Metcalf grid you
know a decade almost to go and we knew
about it it was a professional kind of a
test run this is well done look up the
Metcalf attack on the grid it was done
years ago we investigated it was a
professional group that did it it was
like a dress rehearsal I don't know if
Russia or China or who was behind it but
they did a professional years ago in
2013. this is old stuff just like the
the threat of EMP we've known about it
for decades check this out let me read
this on the morning of April 16 2013 a
team of gunmen using rifles opened find
the Metcalf transmission substation
severely damaging 17 Transformers and
and they said it was sophisticated and
what was the reason for them doing it it
was it does a test to see if they could
take it down and the thing is you don't
have to take down you know there's
there's thousands of these stations but
there's critical nodes and if you take
down you know 10 or 12 critical nodes
you can take the whole grid down and the
worst thing is without getting in too
much details you need to watch a
documentary grid down power up EX
explains this a hundred times better
than what I'm going to do in the next 30
seconds but you do a coordinated attack
on the grid it could be a Cyber attack
it could be solar first if there's a
surge in the grid it destroys these
Transformers these big giant devices and
it takes you months to replace a few of
them if a lot of them are destroyed the
electric grid is down for a year under
good conditions or more and we've known
about this and there's five different
ways this could happen Cyber attack
physical attack solar flares
electromagnetic pulse I'm forgetting the
fifth again watch this documentary grid
down power up our grid is highly
vulnerable it's our Achilles heel if
North Korea wants to destroy the United
States they can do it they got an ICBM
that can reach here they do not need a
lot of nuclear weapons they don't need
accuracy at all well one or two high in
the atmosphere over the US and you
destroy our Electric System the
electromagnetic both destroys our system
for over a year for the whole country
for the whole country for most United
States I don't North Korea has weapons
that can do that Yep they're low you'll
see their nuclear weapons have all kinds
of effects thermal radiation Alpha
radiation beta they're optimized to do
maximum EMP yield the Russians work with
them to do that and this has been
published open source it was
Intelligence agencies but they published
open source saying that the Russians
helped North Korea develop their nuclear
weapons for maximum EMP effect because
North Korea is never going to build you
know a first strike capability on our
huge nuclear system but they only need
one or two inaccurate high in the
atmosphere explosions over the U.S and
at greatest down for over a year and in
that time according to a congressional
study you know led by a former CIA
director a former Navy Admiral their
estimate was that when this happens you
could lose 90 percent of the US
population there's no economic
production there's no gas line there is
no Municipal Water Systems you'll have
no water in this house we will no you
won't yeah we will you're on the
municipal Waters no we're not okay you
may yes see I thought you were still in
the city here we are not no are you
kidding 90 of Americans are in cities or
suburbs they'll have no municipation
every water system
either from starving to death or from
people going out stealing for food every
everybody who comes here they're like I
had to drive up a strange winding
Mountain Road to get here we're elevated
several hundred feet like we're up a
mountain and we have well water and two
local water sources now for the new
place we're setting up we actually have
a we have a ton of backup power and here
we have we have miniature solar here so
we have this big massive battery and
then we have a bunch of really small
batteries that are portable and then
they have solar panels that you actually
have to physically lay out and position
properly not easy to do at the other uh
the new property we're setting up we
have installed professional solar with a
ridiculous amount of backup batteries
so the amount of power generated from
the Sun exceeds the amount that the bet
uh the uh the pot the batteries drain so
as long as you're operating through the
day only at night does it power down but
then it immediately goes back to full as
soon as the sun comes up not perfect
absolutely not perfect I'd probably be
comfortable if I use one of the streams
to create a water wheel power generator
of some Source or just a bike some kind
of way to get power because you you're
half correct we wouldn't lose water
because we're not a municipal water but
we need electricity for our pump so
otherwise we're manually pumping water
but worst case scenarios we do what they
did in the olden days and we either
carry bales of water up the hill which
we can do or we we build a pump or dig a
well or something
I think uh the me and the people here
we've been reading so much about this
stuff non-stop for the past three or
four years five years heck 10 years that
uh
look we've been saying on the show get
chickens get get some small goats some
uh what the the Nigerian dwarf goats or
whatever get something get away from the
cities I've had a lot of people message
saying they moved out of the city they
got they're they're on well water
they're more sustainable they've got
chickens hey I'll tell you what
if these people who are attacking the
power substations succeed because we've
been seeing reports of it all over the
country or North Korea fires an EMP what
you're saying makes the most sense you
want to win a war you don't want you
don't need to wipe a city out with
massive destructive force that's a waste
of energy that's that's that's that's
that's a lack of strategy One EMP
disables your opponent and then you've
won so what will the people in the
cities do yeah right they're gonna have
no water how many days until they start
eating each other and drinking each
other's blood
and again The Marauder thought it
doesn't have to be prepared for because
if you can't defend your preparations
and your facilities the people who
aren't prepared which is the vast
majority will come and take your
supplies and your solar systems and all
that that's right but you know I'm just
mentioning a couple of it's we actually
track 50 of them and I'm not sure which
one is the worst but the one that right
now is sounding the most alarm bills for
us is h5n1avian flu because it mutated
last year it's not the same virus and
it's wrong to call it bird flu it's now
bird and mammal flu that virus is
mutating and spreading amongst mammal
populations minks sea lions lots of
different populations let me pull up the
story we have this from CNN World
explosion of C excuse me explosion of
sea lion deaths in Peru amid deadly bird
flu outbreak so now what are they saying
thousands of sea lions in Peru have died
amid an outbreak of bird flu bird flu is
not only passed into mammals it's
passing into many other mammals this is
a sixty percent mortality rate
I'm sure the most conspiracy-minded
individuals are thinking that it was all
intentional but I've got to say guys if
you think that they took bird flu and
then did gain of function research to
make it transmissible among mammals I
have to say you're completely right from
science.org controversial experiments
that could make bird flu more risky
poised to resume to gain of function
projects halted more than four years ago
have passed new U.S review processes so
uh in February of 2019 and we haven't
mentioned this before they began working
on h5n1 to make it transmissible among
mammals now why would you go and do that
and now it is bouncing around mammals
and it does have a 60 mortality rate
that's correct they actually did it the
first time back in 2011 uh they did it
and uh for a while they tried to stop
publishing it but they ultimately ended
up letting letting them publish and I'll
explain why they do it why the
government does it I just don't want
your bloggers to take my head off for
defending them but this is why the guy
you're going to take your head up no
matter what I know this is why the
government does gain a function research
they do it with this reasoning hey
eventually h5n1 will mutate to become
human human transmissible it'll happen
naturally and biologists have said that
and they're right it happens all the
time virus is always mutating so they
say what we're going to do is we're
going to speed it up in the lab we're
going to develop a human human
contagious or mammal to mammal
contagious version now once we've got
this in the lab we'll keep it in the lab
and we'll develop vaccines so when the
natural happens we'll prepare that's
their argument for doing it but the
problem here is back in 2011 I don't
care if they do that at Fort Dietrich
which by the way isn't too far from you
you know if the Army's doing biological
research for defensive Reasons I'm for
that but when they released it and
publish how you do it so that anyone
from Al-Qaeda to North Korea to Syria
you name it I could do it I've got the
knowledge it's low-tech way to do it and
you publish results now you've just
increased our odds of any nut case doing
it and then releasing it so it's
happening naturally but the threat is
not low that's that's what I was arguing
here the threat is not low because a
natural mutation may occur the threat is
high because it has mutated it is now
spreading amongst mammals it started
with minks last year sea lions other
things may be spreading now but they're
not the only threat you could
deliberately do it in a lab you could
deliberately do it a low-tech way in the
basement I'm saying bad guys could be
doing it now too because we've published
how to do it it's very well known so to
me it's inevitable biologists have used
that word in Congressional testimony
warning Congress we must be ready for
Avian fluid h5n1 to be spreading amongst
humans they've been warning Congress for
a decade now has anything been done not
a damn thing what can they do just like
that there's a lot of things that if one
thing to do the first thing is just warn
people don't have the CDC saying oh it's
low risk it's not low risk all kinds of
medical groups are saying watch out it's
coming the probability of a pandemic has
gone up but the CDC keeps it in Center
for Disease Control keeps saying it's
low and it's not and the CDC is not
giving an honest warning about it the
threat is up a lot because it's now
mutated and it's now spreading amongst
mammal populations which means as that
virus mutates it's far more likely when
it's mutating amongst sea lions or
ferrets or mink to now become human
human transmissible so the risk is up it
is not still low risk like they've been
saying can you calculate that risk no
you can't you can't put a number to it
but that's why the CDC absolutely cannot
say it's low risk it's an unknown risk I
think it could be very high probability
it could be 50 percent it's going to
happen this year 75 percent CDC cannot
know that so why are they announcing its
low risk to humans when you cannot know
that without going into great detail let
me just say I think the people who watch
this show I think myself personally I'm
pretty sure the other people in the room
have very little faith in the CDC for a
variety of reasons yeah the CDC wants to
prevent Panic one which is why they'll
say don't worry about it secondly when
it comes to covid the way they handle
covet they did not talk about
prophylactic measures they never really
talked about prevention they talked
about how to deal with it once it
already hits I don't want to eject the
thing or do the thing where's my vitamin
D I don't want to deviate from the bird
flu so this is why I think we haven't
heard about how to prevent or prepare
for how to heal from this stuff before
it gets you because I I if the
methodology is let's heal it once it
strikes I think the CDC is completely
inept or malicious and they're incapable
of properly advising it was so bad that
Stephen Crowder got multiple strikes and
it's not just them it's you know the big
tech industry uh Stephen Crowder got I
think two strikes on YouTube for talking
about what the CDC was saying that's how
insane the whole thing is generally let
me let me just say about all of this I
don't think anyone is going to give us
an honest assessment of what this is and
what might happen but I will say I do
believe based on what we've already seen
well I should say this the news is
reported the gain of function research
to make bird flu transmissible among
mammals happened a decade ago and they
kept doing it and how and now that the
department of energy and FBI are saying
lab leak how hard would it be for this
to leak from a lab accidents happen or
Worse still as you mentioned bad guys
can do it very easily sure and bad guys
can take out of a lab very easily they
should not be doing these things we've
been warning people our members we've
been putting on our newsletter you need
to be prepared because there's so many
ways this could happen if I were Putin
you know a ruthless guy not doing well
in the Ukraine war and the U.S and West
European providing so much support if he
releases clandestinely so you can't even
punish him for it he releases a virus
like avian flu human human transmissible
over here we are not going to be
supporting Ukraine we're going to be
struggling to survive losing tens
perhaps hundreds of millions of people
over here we're not helping Ukraine he
now has a free reign there and if he's
developed the virus he may already have
the vaccine developed so he can give it
to Russian people he wants to survive
and for the rest of the world they
suffer the worst pandemic the worst
disaster in human history what are some
prophylactic measures that people can
take to protect themselves
masks aren't going to work the only
thing you can do is you have to stay
away from people and tell the virus
plays out now here's this is a bad news
good news the good news is when you have
a virus this lethal it's going to kill
people 60 lethal it's going to kill
people so massively people are going to
immediately isolate for long periods of
time and the virus will die out fairly
quickly the viruses it's it's not good
for a virus to have super high lethality
because you end up killing off your
virus you can't survive well if it's low
level like covet or flu you keep you
keep spreading it all the time this you
will not you will have to be isolated
for at least months perhaps over a year
so you've got to have food and the
ability to defend your food which is the
other reason why there's no warning of
this coming out if you weren't about a
collapse you have to warn about Marauder
threats it happened in Katrina it's
certainly going to happen if the grid is
down and there's food product it's going
to happen you got to have guns well I
talk about and the government is not
going to tell people hey you need to
have a lot of guns and by the way
assault rifles and those high capacity
magazines that's what you need if you're
going to defend against Marauders no no
don't don't uh misinterpret he said
assault rifle with high capacity
magazines we're talking fully automatic
select fire with 100 round drums or
something like that and he said yeah he
said
he sells with an S so multiple that's
maybe more than one now if you want to
mention something like a standard
semi-auto standard capacity we're
talking about an AR-15 with 30 round
magazines that's not what he said he
said well you can't even buy those in
Colorado those are illegal Clips in
Colorado so you buy them in Nebraska
elsewhere
they come in illegally with them and
like what I think what he was saying is
like a 50 BMG
um you know mounted uh butterfly trigger
let me know what you think about this I
was thinking Auto defense turrets you
know we'll build big towers and then
we'll have on them just Sentry turrets
that you know sweep left and right and
then at a certain time they will go into
you know full defense mode and if you uh
you know
you know I wouldn't recommend that I
just use you know people with weapons is
the low-cost smart way to do that but
you need a lot of people to defend
yourself in a collapse and you need
assault rifles and high capacity Clips
because there could be Marauder groups
that have 50 100 people in them we got
we got two million Americans in jail if
the electric grid goes down are you
going to keep two million people they're
going to come out they're not they're
going to stay and they're going to use
the prisons as fortresses and and they
need food there's not enough of course
and they're going to sell out scouting
parties who come back to the prisons
because the prisons are fortified and
armed and you're not breaking in and
they can control like I think real no
one's raiding a prison and prisons will
be raining no realistically the people
will be locked in their cells and
they'll be left no because when the
power when the power goes off the
Shell's open the automatic that's
horrible the cell manufacturers
if the power goes off and there's no one
there you'll have you'll have people
dying yeah Katrina
but it doesn't matter when the when when
the system breaks someone's going to go
in from the outside and they're gonna
have friends and family who are in
prison and they are going to take that
whole place over and it is a fortress I
doubt it
it's also the most aggressive people in
society I feel like they'll be dead
within a week in a city because the
doors lock and they all just starve all
the guards leave you're acting like
people in jail have no family
what do they get how are they going to
get in the building they're going to
drive their truck 100 miles an hour and
slam into a Walsh it's like eight eight
feet wide concrete prisons have fences
and and there's gonna be prison guards
who are going to be like here's the key
and they're gonna run and lose I think
all the guards would bail of these two
million people none of the jail about a
million were in there for you know drug
charges they're not really that bad of
people so no they're not going to be
killed off or left they're going to get
out and they're completely unprepared
maybe they'll base out of the prison but
they have no preparations that means
they're gonna have to be Marauders
people in gangs are already but you're
indicating like why we would lock them
in the cell and leave them there to die
because they would otherwise turn into
Marauders I'm just trying to say there's
a there's millions of Americans are
going to be Marauder so the minimum you
got two million in prison and a million
gang members but normal people when
they're told you know stay at home all
government can tell you due to collapses
go home stay home well for most people
that's the death sentence so after you
start starving to death are you going to
stay at home and quietly politely die
are you going to go out and steal food
to keep your family you're going to go
steal I'm saying we're going to come
outside one day and there's going to be
some dude with suspenders and a flannel
shirt and a handlebar mustache and we're
gonna hear the chicken squawking and
we're gonna walk outside with the you
know lever action rifle and be like hey
and there's going to be some New York
hipster big look I'm so hungry and he's
gonna try and run away the chicken you
know you get to that point honestly it's
yeah I mean it gets re it's the ugliness
love the level of ugliness that happens
with the type of scenario that we're
talking about you're not we can't really
actually articulate it properly on
YouTube because you'll get booted like
someone coming on your if you got
chickens and there's someone messing
around with your chickens and you you're
three months into a global collapse
shoot on site
like drop them watch the last the season
finale of The Last of Us from last night
if you really want to understand what
what uh what it means watch video from
Syria the I understand the last of us is
fictional
but if you want to understand what will
happen when the when the collapse
happens
just watch that episode I don't want to
spoil it because it literally just came
out last night because and people are
gonna don't spoil it but uh
watch what the good guys do there are no
good guys that's the point yeah you'll
be like my God because when it comes to
protecting those yourself and those you
care about the guy who comes onto your
property for chickens he's he's he's got
he he pulls up in his truck and he's got
his starving 10 year old daughter and he
says don't worry honey I'm getting you
food and then him and his his brother
and his kid and his son are like we have
to do this or we die and then they sneak
around your property and then you're in
your house going I see people outside
with guns don't worry honey I'm gonna
protect us and then you kill each other
there's no good guys there's no bad guys
there I'm not going to die and if I have
to kill you to do it that's what these
people are thinking look you'll you can
tell the the serious people by the ones
that have like people impaled on spikes
in their yard like that's it gets real
real brutal real real fast have you seen
uh I think what is it uh either it's I
think this was in Yellowstone actually
in in Yellowstone it might have been a
flashback or it might have been 1883. I
think it was Yellowstone they catch
cattle thieves and he kills them and
then one one guy who's mortally injured
he puts a rope around his neck and then
pulls him hoists him up to hang him and
they write in blood cattle thieves yeah
he was like anybody who sees this knows
what happens it's crazy to think that
back in the day
they're like they would kill a group of
men
mercilessly like and brutally and then
leave their rotting corpses for everyone
to see for taking cattle because taking
the Cattleman you die in the winter so
they were like nope no games yep no
games that's right you were retired
Colonel yes so you've seen I mean I
don't know would you ever experience
battle did you I've been to Iraq I mean
I'm Air Force so not at the pointy end
of the spear more on the receiving ends
of mortar rounds and stuff but you know
you don't have to go to wreck you could
see it in Katrina you know you could see
how people panicked and would steal and
were looting and we're taking advantage
of stuff and yeah again I'm not just I
mean I wouldn't blame someone if they're
starving to death trying to take their
family or keep them alive they're going
to go out and steal and try to survive
so you have to deal with the marauder
threat and the probability of collapse
is going up things like h5n1 are
vulnerable Electric System and then new
technologies I mean Elon Musk warns
about artificial intelligence about
every other week or two you know he
provides you a warning on that there are
a lot of new technologies and our
economy with its fragileness to Cyber
attack there's so many ways as I said we
track 50 different trigger events any
one of which could lead to a collapse or
it could be nothing it could be
something like you know in the United
Kingdom in 2011 in London one night
there's some altercation started with
police there was violence it spread all
over London and the next day they woke
up and they said what in the hell was
that thank God it's over and then the
next night it started again in London
that it spread all over the United
Kingdom all the major cities people were
killed defending their businesses it was
a collapse going on loss of Law and
Order widespread and there was no
trigger event so after the next election
Ray dalio you know perhaps one of the
smartest men alive in the U.S today the
founder CEO of Bridgewater the most
biggest most successful hedge fund he's
estimated we've got a 30 percent of
Civil War civil unrest massive violence
after our next presidential election
because we are so divided divided and so
split that any possible issue in that
election are people just not wanting to
accept the result you could have
violence break out and it can spiral out
of control I know this is something that
that our that you know viewers of this
show hear all the time but really you
need to purchase firearms ammunition and
get training you need to know how to use
firearms and ammunition you know how to
load magazines how to clear stoppages
malfunctions and stuff like that when
you go to a Firearms class they're not
teaching you safety stuff the safety
stuff is very very basic you go over
that and it only takes a little while
they're teaching you how to fix your gun
if there's a problem when you're in a
gunfight people should learn how to do
that not just that when the if slash
when a collapse happens people from the
cities many of them will lose their
thumbs and I'm talking like I have to
imagine I mean a massive percentage of
them
because I can't tell you how many times
I've seen people hold a gun wrong
and it's scary when you go to a range
and someone's given instruction and the
first thing someone does is pick up the
gun and put their hand over the yeah and
then you and they stop never do that
again
I've seen people actually get ready to
shoot after being told not to do it and
still put their hand over the back of
the gun like do you want to have your
thumb get ripped off you were told not
to do that I have seen people I mean
there's viral videos of this where a
guy's in a Range you can look at the
video up and then he's like he shoots
and then he takes the gun and he like
waves it around and they tackle him
these people don't get it it's like you
can you need to have basic understanding
of this stuff but some people just don't
get it it's gonna get bad I have to
imagine New York City is going to be the
last place on the planet anyone's going
to want to be if the system does
collapse well they won't stay there
they'll leave and they'll end up going
to the areas all around New York City if
they can get it it'll it'll it'll you
wanna I don't know if you can call it
civil war but it will be if a collapse
happens when the first three days the
entire New York Metro will be riots
ransacking shootings murders I think a
lot of people will be trapped in their
houses and then after after a half a day
when they're desperately thirsty and
there's no water one one person's gonna
be like we need to find water man there
ain't gonna be any water anywhere so
they're going to go outside and then
someone's gonna walk up shoot them and
take whatever they can or let's get hit
by a sniper like they'll walk outside
and bang and they'll be down like kind
of after three days of fortification in
a chaos situation
there's no reason maybe they'll walk up
to you because they don't want to expose
their body to other sniper fire like
it's gonna be about hiding in buildings
and shooting out windows no because what
you can stand outside why would you
shoot someone why would you sit in my
way just to shoot people for like if you
if you can't go out there and like
collect their stuff what what's the
point you're gonna expose yourself
because you're going to make a lot of
noise you're going to draw attention to
yourself
no you wouldn't waste ammo but if
someone goes outside to look for stuff
likely someone will rob them to try and
go raid there or or more importantly
you'll lock your door in your apartment
but like we can't go outside and then
all of a sudden you hear bangs and then
you're like what's happening and then
you hear a a loud a loud bang the first
the first bang was the door being kicked
out been the second bang was the
personal leather being killed as the
people ransacked to steal their Chef
Boyardee because they're not going to
die and there are people in cities who
have guns and the people in cities who
have gone to the people who don't follow
the law I don't even know how to talk
about what how people in a city can
defend themselves in that situation is
that even a viable conversation no you
need to get out of a city even a big
suburban area you won't survive a long
collapse there you got to get out you
have no water you can't raise food and
there's just too many bad people around
you need to get out yep you're you're in
trouble if if the power grid goes down
like I said it's something around 10
percent of the population will survive
after a year because I mean a bunch of
people that are you know a significant
portion of the population is going to
die just because they don't get the
medication that they need diabetes
you're gone if you have if you have any
kind of any kind of heart medication
whatever you're gone yeah and government
regulations prevent us from stockpiling
that kind of stuff the government is the
biggest barrier to preparation all their
regulations and rules they're outlawing
wood stoves Woodstock is Army and yes we
got solar but if we're going to heat and
we're going to cook meals we need wood
stoves
a lot of areas you can make one with a
tin can not a really good one and yeah
capacity one what made I made up I made
the point a few months ago that one of
the benefits we have as a civil as as
civilized society is the I would just
say passive knowledge that is we know
smelting ore is a thing we don't really
know how to do it I mean I don't but
just just the knowledge of its existence
means that in the event of a collapse we
could eventually start trying to work
out how this thing had been done whereas
thousands of years ago before the
discovery of you know certain
Technologies they didn't know they
couldn't even begin to try and find
things because they didn't know it
existed right well that's a good sense
the bad side is you know when the Grid's
down and you're back to the 1800s most
Americans can't survive in the 1800s to
do my point is I think
so I'm I made this point and then all of
a sudden a bunch of like weird left-wing
channels where like Tim Poole thinks he
can blacksmith and I was like my point
was that I can't my point was that none
of us can my point is that something is
so basic as taking a rock heating it up
and making Metals that's been done for
thousands of years the average person
has no comprehension of we know it
exists so we can maybe after a few years
figure it out but my point is like I
think the people who watch this show the
people who are aware of this already are
likely the people who would survive
likely not everybody
we're talking about 10 of the population
and the pop when the power goes out I'm
willing to bet that it's 95 of people
who watch shows like this well you got
to have a lot of people to do this if
you're going to survive in a remote area
with Marauders around you have to have a
lot of guards on Duty at once and I
don't mean two guards that's not a lot
of guards if you've got you know 30
people and you're hiding out in some
rural area and you got two guards on
duty at night that means the two of us
can take you out because all we do is we
watch you clandestinely we figure out
you got two Gods we know where you are
we set up our shots 2 30 or 3 in the
morning on the walkie-talkies you got
your guy yep I'm ready five four three
two one we shoot at the same time your
two guards are now dead did someone
inside hear our gunshot they might have
but 2 30 in the morning they wake up
they heard a noise do they hear anything
else now it's completely quiet they go
back to bed so the other 28 people are
sleeping inside two of us go in if
you're lucky we just steal stuff if
you're not lucky these Marauders Now
kill you while you're asleep let me you
need a lot of guards you need a lot of
discipline and system that's why fortied
Ranch is set up to have a lot of guards
on duty a lot everyone all our members
have weapons the numbers and we can
defend ourselves but a typical person he
says oh I'm going to build a little
house somewhere and my family will come
and we'll survive you might survive the
first month or two but after the the
easy targets are gone and Marauders are
going elsewhere and everyone's left New
York City and they're all out in the
rural areas looking for food they'll get
you so I was uh this this past weekend
hanging out at the casino and uh the
conversation of The Last of Us comes up
the TV show and this one guy it was one
of the funniest things ever so uh
someone the issue of Mario Brothers
comes up because a guy has a little
Mario Brothers toy uh and then I
mentioned that the Mushroom Kingdom
people like toad are cordyceps infected
humans because the fungus is growing out
of their head it's a joke and then uh
some guys like hey have you seen the
last of us that show is really great and
I was like yeah I actually really enjoy
it and then he looks around the table
and goes except for that one episode and
then everyone starts going like yup and
see the thing is you're not allowed to
talk politics when you're at the casino
at the tables because they don't want
any animosity but there's an episode
where there's a lot of gay sex in it and
so but everyone in meters are talking
about it now the reason I bring it up in
this context is the guy then says I
don't understand why movies and shows
keep doing this stuff to me it was
actually astounding to hear because I've
been talking about it for 10 years why
we're seeing more and more of this the
reason I'm bringing up is not to rehash
any kind of openness but to point out
regular people have no idea what the is
going on at all and I don't blame the
guy he's just some dude who probably
works his job then he goes and watches
TV shows with the wife hangs out on the
weekend at the casino and it's confused
that's why he's seeing gay sex in a TV
show me I'm like oh I told them
Hollywood has is threatened to withhold
tax credits from companies unless they
put this stuff in he didn't know that I
think the people who are watching shows
like this are the people who probably
will survive not every single one of you
sorry because I think that would be
absurd to say 100 of the Tim cast
audience will make it I don't know but a
large proportion a large portion because
so many of these people who watch have
already said I've moved away from cities
I've gotten chickens I've tried to be
more self-sufficient and more
self-sustainable that's the kind of
attitude you need if you're gonna make
it now if you really want to guarantee
you make it you just go full prepper
because the preppers are going to be the
one who are laughing in the end they got
nothing to worry about they got three
years worth of beans you know Frozen or
whatever in a sub basement the rest of
the people in the cities
I don't know a couple days they'll be
drinking blood I'm not even kidding
there's you can't drink this in New York
what's your water supply if you know
where to look there's actually a creek
that goes under the city and there's
this video where a guy hops over like a
six foot wall into a space between a
building and he says they've preserved
this stream that used to be here okay
great you got some really dirty and
disgusting freshwater good luck as well
drink the Hudson better than the salt
water I guess no most people are going
to be thirsty
and when all the water is gone and so
first of all the water pumps aren't
going to work a lot of the water
pressure comes naturally because the the
water comes from an elevated source
so I think up to like I think New York
has a few stories of water pressure
interestingly but all that's going to
fail because it requires systems and
maintenance and one water main break so
nobody's paying attention to it no one's
working on it water shuts down very very
quickly I think within a few days water
stops working
then bottled water is gone Gatorade is
gone whatever whatever drinks people
have those are dehydrating you they're
not hydrating you the sugary drinks
that's all gone within a matter of few
days not being replenished then someone
finally says I'm thirsty many of these
people start leaving
shooting starts happening people are
starting to get hungry or not the food's
going away a lot of it's spoiling I
would say within a few days people are
drinking blood because there's nothing
else to drink there's no water what do
you do people are going to become very
very desperate you'll die within a week
with no water
so they'll start walking but how far can
you walk out of New York before you find
water you're not gonna find water
the average person will not do it some
people will don't get me wrong some
people are smart they'll follow an
animal that's one of the things they do
you uh what they what they say you do is
this
if you find a wild animal
you capture it and and make it wait for
a little while I think I think I learned
this on Joe Rogan then you release it
and Chase it down and it will it will
immediately go to it's it's known water
source I think he was talking about how
they find water in Africa they catch a
baboon and tie it up yeah baboons once
it gets really dehydrated they let it go
because they have a secret water source
and then it'll run full speed and you
just follow it to the Water Source some
people are smart enough because they
watch they listen to Joe Rogan they'll
know how to do that the average person
is going to go wandering around going
does anybody have any water does anybody
have any water
it's going to be brutal
buy guns and ammunition get out of
cities I mean it's you can do a lot fix
the world man like I I don't I'm
not satisfied leaving the world shittier
than it was when I was born that's
that's not that's not the issue and the
issue is
the world is an imperfect machine
there's I just saw you smiling when you
were saying like how bad it's gonna get
yeah like I saw the smile on your face
it's not good oh come on man that's
disgusting I'm not bad oh I'm so happy
that that's that's ridiculous that you
would imply well you talk about like how
fun it'll be to live in a van down by
the river like it's not good that
stuff's bad it's bad I'm talking about
enjoying rolling up my sleeves for A
Hard Day's work and getting away from
all this stuff I'm not talking about
anything good that comes from people
killing each other to drink each other's
blood a good thing
a good thing is trying to be done is
that documentary I talked about grid
down power-up it's not just a
documentary about how bad and vulnerable
Electric System David Tice the producer
of it he talks he's got a movement going
to try to get people to pressure the
politicians and the utility companies to
harden our electric grid we can Harden
our electric grid it's not hard to do
it's really not that expensive yet
some billions of dollars but compared to
the the consequences it's cheap to
harden it so grid down power up is all
about trying to get that done to get
people to fix one of our biggest
vulnerabilities or got our electric
system as for pandemics you can't stop
h5n1 natural mutations I think our
intelligence Community probably has been
successful in stopping a lot of
terrorists doing it and I'm not going to
get details I don't know them I could
speculate that was my career but I think
I suspect there have been people trying
to re to release h5n1 human human
contagious viruses and our intelligence
Community around the world they're very
good at finding people like that so we
may have already shut some down so
government may be doing some good in
that regard but you're not going to stop
this forever you're going to have to
deal with an h5n1 pandemic and we should
be preparing for it which means huge
stockpiles of food should be around
stockpiles of water the ability to
operate when when bad things happen
that's what we should be working for you
know well the government's got it for
them they've got Mount weather sidear
Raven Rock all these great facilities to
keep the top government officials alive
and they ought to be warning the public
there are some bad things coming we
can't stop all of it you need to be
prepared to survive a collapse and
they're not doing that they're dishonest
I'll tell you when and I I know
everybody's heard me say it a couple
times but when I started promoting safe
and readymeals.com emergency food stuff
this was right at the beginning of the
pandemic the Market's collapsing and a
whole bunch of corporate press left his
publication started making fun of the
idea how stupid are you to buy emergency
food how embarrassing and I'm just gonna
be like they're not doing that anymore
this was they still losses in the
Washington Post oh wow the last few
months Preppers were right this was in
The Washington Post Bloomberg News kind
of you know left-leaning perhaps media
they've admitted the preppers are right
all along by the way this is the picture
on the front page that's 40 Ranch West
Virginia they showed our facility oh
yeah we got no credit for it they didn't
list
West Virginia I think people don't know
typing is recognized as being good but
still the government isn't coming out
saying h5n1 is a threat you need to be
prepared and one of the reasons they
don't want to do it is they don't want
people buying guns which you absolutely
have to have and especially military
capable guns with large clips because
you've got to deal with Marauder threats
so they're not being honest but even
even the left recognizing that you do
need to be prepared it was funny when
the pandemic was starting and a bunch of
liberals were lining up outside of gun
stores and there was a viral video of a
guy he said he he was saying something
like stop coming to me and getting mad
that I can't sell you a gun you voted
for these laws so these California
liberals walk in and they try try to buy
a gun he'd be like okay come back in a
week and I'll let you know and they go
what do you mean I need a gun now and he
goes well you can't have one you voted
for this it's what you wanted now you
don't get one get a long gun chambered
in 5.56 get nine get a handgun in nine
millimeter these are the most common
calibers in the country you need you
know how to use these things go to go
get training get food this is not it's
not super difficult to do these things
and it's not super expensive either but
it's been it's been a long time that a
lot of people have been talking about
the possibility of
significant consequences or some kind of
collapse or whatever I know there was a
bunch of people that bought their first
firearm in 2020 during the summer of
love and stuff yeah training just go out
and do it you're never you're not going
to regret it it's gonna be uh you know a
couple afternoons or a couple days to
get training just go out and do it
someone said the Judge 45 Cal and 410 uh
and there's also the Governor
I have the governor oh yeah I fired that
thing yeah with Fort it's a what is
Smith and Wesson I think yeah it's uh
yeah 45 uh uh if you use the uh the moon
Clips I think it's they're called that
you can do a 45 ACP 45 long or uh 410
yeah
shooting 410 of that thing pretty pretty
surprised the judge the ability it's my
snake gun you know I got the 410 shelves
that there's the snake but you got the
45 if it's a Marauder earlier when I
brought it up or or for for they have
Buckshot with a slug behind it the one
other thing I agree with your two third
we use this is the 12 gauge pump that's
awesome because especially if you're in
your house or close quarters and if if
you're not a good shot and most people
you're going to be scared you know it's
a lot a lot easier to hit with the 12
gauge when you're shooting that than an
AR also guns seem to have flashlights
now flashlight on it a semi-automatic
shotgun I think is is better the recoil
on on a pump shotgun is pretty intense
so a lot of people when we'll bring them
to the range they'd be like I'll do the
shotgun it's like that's actually going
to hurt you the most you're better off
doing something we're trying to help
people make it more affordable so you
can get a pump you know Walmart's not
selling as much as they used to you and
still find some Walmarts that'll sell
you a nice pump you know Browning or
something for 180 you can get a
Remington 870 for less than 2 200 bucks
and they've been making that thing over
on Mossberg 500 something like that
those are pump shotguns and there's
they're super super reliable get these
types of firearms have been around most
of them have been around for 70 or more
years nine millimeters been around for
decades and decades 556 has been around
forever and ever and ever same thing
with 45 these are not newfangled things
the operating systems of all your
firearms that you're gonna buy they're
100 years old they all they're not yes
you can go and buy these things you know
while you still have the chance yeah
might I recommend a CalTech KSG 25 hey
there holds 25 shotgun shells two mag
tubes and it can switch between the two
actually uh I I don't want to give
anyone any advice on any of this stuff
I'm gonna tell you I have one of these
and the reason I think it's really good
is not only can it hold uh 12 shells per
magazine tube the the ability to switch
between the two you got 12 in each and
then one uh uh one round ready to go is
that you can put an all one side bird
one side bump and so or one rubber and
one lethal so you can flip the switch to
the left and then you're all non-lethal
you can flip to the right and now you're
lethal so I think that that's actually
you know tremendous versatility but
that's just me 12 gauge is great I like
that thing a lot is that the one that
Crowder purchased no no no that was a
Sig M400 wow talk about a beauty of a
rifle so you know I've got like a
there's a local shop and I bought uh
mil-spec 556 air 15. and it's it's nice
and then Crowder got me the Sig M400 and
uh it's just substantially better you
know earlier I was kind of like Tim yes
you're smiling but like I think I know
that you want the best for people but I
I I I get concerned about the fantasy of
this because I play a lot of video games
I have my whole life like oh yeah
survival games and even like a genre now
it's really weird of like you're you're
searching through post-apocalyptic
houses and stuff it's disturbing to like
it's a fan I I don't want the fantasy to
ever like overcome reality and think
like that would be I'm preparing for
that so let's make that happen kind of
thing I get what you're saying but I
think that we are at the very least the
fact that we bring up the the low
survivability rate the the realistic
scenario of one in ten people making it
more than a year I think at least we're
we're looking at it in a fairly sober
kind of way because we aren't it's not
like we're like oh man everything's
gonna be great it'll be cool we are
talking about you know a death rate of
90 and that's uh that's um a vector so
like you're gonna say five ten percent
of the people will be left over after
one year that that's an angle on its way
down so you'll imagine there's many many
less yeah might even be less than 10 of
10 after two years I don't know and we'd
like good people to be amongst that 10
not mainly Marauders but you know back
to the you know the moral issues you
know we don't think we're going to get
in a fire fight at fortitude Ranch
because we have cleared lines of Defense
walls guard posts were designed to be a
survival facility some Marauder group's
going to look at us and they're going to
see every one of our members outside is
armed that's a requirement in the
collapse you'll have your work with
they're going to look at us and they're
going to say uh-uh I'm not attacking
these they'll leave us alone so we won't
get in a firefight so we won't be
putting our members in a position where
they're shooting other people hopefully
you'll do it with defensive prowess
instead of heads on spikes correct
absolutely defensive you know we're not
an offensive militia we defend our
private property we've got our farm
animals we've got our food stockpiles
our solar systems propane generators
we've got everything we need we don't
you know we'll go out to hunt when it's
safe a little off our property but we
defend our property and I don't think
we'll be attacked because our defenses
are so good the Marauders will go
elsewhere but Ian why not both heads on
spikes why not both only if they're
skulls because the the meaty the skulls
are inside yeah but the meat what if you
convert the body of the marauder into a
biofuel to run the generator only if the
head can be on this bike out front
though oh I'm going to give the details
of our operations man if if a Marauder
does attack us and they get killed um
you know we're probably gonna
bury their bodies with our tractors and
wearing our chem bio suits in case
there's a virus set will bury their
bodies in a shallow grave where our
chickens can benefit from the worms they
produce so we will put them to use to
have maximum food I don't know if I
would want to eat chickens or chicken
eggs that came from them it's the worms
it's the worms eating your flesh they're
perfectly fine Circle of Life do you
take like one really big Sniper Tower do
you have like one one really tall tower
I don't want to give out our locations
one of our locations is of a very tall
log Tower it's actually the tallest log
building in the world it's five stories
tall tall octar salad not West Virginia
but most of our places no we're not tie
up but we tend to be like West Virginia
or Tennessee location we're in forests
and usually we're surrounded by public
forests so you can't do any really long
distance shooting we're in a clear trees
for lines of fire but it'll be close
what's the other reason why 12 gauge is
fine because most of our shooting I
think will be within 40 yards or so but
again I don't think have to do shooting
at fortitude Ranch because they'll see
you know we'll have walls up we'll be
behind walls guard posts 100 people Plus
at every location with arms they're not
going to bother us because again if you
get shot in a collapse you know there's
no mash units there's no helicopter
evaluation there's no hospital so you're
going to die the only reason we have
clinics the Marauders aren't going to
have that people don't understand uh
infection is so insanely serious that
you get shot it's not just like well I
got shots like Oh no you're likely going
to get infected you better get that out
get it cleaned and get it taken care of
yeah so you should stockpile antibiotics
who's going to stop you from stockpiling
antibiotics the government you can't do
that that's because you need a
prescription yeah you got to do it and
government government is the biggest
barrier to prepping there is it's
horrible let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button and if you like the
work that we do and you want us to keep
doing that work go to timcast.com click
join us and become a member because uh
as we already saw with BuzzFeed ad rates
ad revenue is dropping rather seriously
and um you know I will say this take
care of yourself first and foremost but
if you have the means the capability and
you like what we do then I would ask you
to become a member so that we can keep
doing this as well because
um if it does get really bad in the
coming months in terms of the financial
crisis well then that's us but you know
what
I'm not going to be somebody who's going
to tell you to prioritize us over
anything you have to do so make sure
your money is going to take care of
yourself your friends your family and
then if you actually have the capability
and want to support us then by all means
do so and uh we'll make it work on our
own as I mentioned part of me is like I
wouldn't mind getting a van and going
living Down by the River but if you like
what we do then support our work all
right I'm not your buddy guy always the
first Super Chat says history repeats
only faces and Tech change Summer of
Love was our Crystal act January 6 was
our reichstag socialists are on the
March again with matching uniforms
symbols and violent ideology yikes yeah
sideways says just learn today that my
credit union has a Dei initiative how
worried should I be
I am uh gonna take a look into our
financial institutions so we we have a
couple different ones that we use one of
them is a very local one which I am have
the most confidence in so
all right let's grab some more
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim the
capital show was top deaf fourth a
second watch more please and but of
course the svb uh bailout happened while
still no ballot for the people of East
Palestine Ohio no Civil War yes
Revolution I agree
yeah I think we'll do more of the uh
Congressional shows the the issue is uh
what Matt Gates was saying is that
Friday morning at 10 A.M was when
everybody did their last vote and they
immediately fly out and leave nobody
wants to drive an hour out of DC then
back then get on a plane at midnight but
he convinced uh rep Bishop to hang out
and so for us it's like dude we will
gladly take a drive down to the Capitol
and do a show from congressional offices
that's amazing and fun
we'll just try and make sure the audio
works next time but uh because you know
two for two two for two but it wasn't
that bad actually I watched it back and
it was just like V it was it was it was
kind of weird something happened where
the like we have the mics really close
but it was like the mics were hyper
sensitive well do you want me to explain
what it was what was it uh for everyone
that's you know giving me all this audio
tips like I don't know what I'm doing
like I'm not a professional
um we were running a line out into a mic
in so that extra 60 B's was really
difficult to deal with and just keeping
the right oh I see the microphone well
that maybe work sometimes but Cloud
won't happen again needed to be pulled
out or something
yeah potentially yeah whatever
but it was fun it was fun so I'll
definitely do more than apparently we
made a bunch of news because Bandon said
something about Elon Elon fired back and
all right
Raymond then says Tim these spot on
guests lately are you a Fed I I I no
this is a thing that we've done
consistently for some reason we have
guests sometimes that just land
perfectly in the news cycle so we have
drew Miller he the CEO of a disaster
preparedness Recreational facility
basically like a prepper company if I'm
being a little bit crass and scheduled
to come on a day literally the first day
for news after major banking collapses
and everyone's worried the financial
system is going to implode and they're
like did you plan this guy to be here
and talk about this stuff and it's like
oh it just it sort of happens I guess
but also I mean look to be honest the
h5n1 stuff that was we were talking
about that a month ago you know and
we're still here talking about this this
breaking update on it so you know
all right we'll grab some more
Pat Meadow says every Tomahawk missile
has 30 pounds of silver in it so every
time a missile is fired that silver
disappears buy silver and super jets
that's right thank you
and also we have news on the Discord
so um it is nearing completion we are
going to have active staff who are
running it the idea is here's the
challenge we ran into we don't we don't
want to get banned but people will come
and try and sabotage it
so we're going to do is
we we were at first advised do a paywall
thing so that you know weirdos who want
to sabotage you won't want to pay to get
in and then we're like yeah but that
means like our regular members who can't
afford it aren't going to be able to
come in so the idea is going to be if
you're a member for at least six months
of the website if you already have that
in your track record or whatever you're
instantly in the uh call-in Suite so we
have like as soon as you remember you
get access to the basic Lounge after six
months the door opens for the VIP lounge
where you can ask to do call-ins and
talk on the show or if you're signing up
as a new member it's 25 bucks to
instantly get access to that room
because we didn't want to make it just
paywalled but we didn't want to have it
so there was no no gate because then
people will come in and screw with us
and then we're going to do an elite
membership club thing that we're trying
to figure out where it's like 100 bucks
a month for a VIP room where we'll
figure something out I don't know that
that just seems like a good idea because
the 100 bucks a month one is going to be
more more like a club with more perks
and benefits than just the lower tier
rooms like maybe even access to the club
at the new coffee shop we're building
something all inclusive and community
building and like something like that
but we'll figure it out but um we got we
got to do all the all the development
for it so it's we've got to set it up so
that it can integrate with the website
that stuff takes time but I'm hearing
good things about it being being ready
to go so uh at about 10 10 we're gonna
do a Members Only Live portion of the
show at timcast.com it'll appear on the
front page
there is a comment section where you can
comment but we're trying we're building
out the Discord so that you can chat in
real time and and we can talk and then
in that uncensored show even pull in
people to have you all talk on the show
and ask the guest a question or ask us
questions I'm really excited for that I
think it'll be really really interesting
so
but we're trying to figure it out all
right let's grab some more Michael says
Tim you're wrong about kidney donors
they live a normal life just with one
kidney the donated kidney has a 15-year
life expectancy but it can last longer I
have a transplanted kidney and pancreas
in October it'll be three years God
bless I appreciate it so I think what I
was trying to say is it right if you're
only on one kidney this my understanding
is there's restrictions you can't drink
there are certain things you got to be
careful of you got to watch your diet
stuff like that
what the hell this study shows that
people who donate a kidney outlive the
average population what 20 years after
donating 85 percent of kidney donors
were still alive expected Survivor rate
was 66 I'm not sure could it but because
they're like if you eat too much of this
or drink you will die and they go okay
I'm gonna be really healthy it's
self-selection bias you can't donate
unless you're in really good health
right yeah
all right Alessio De Monte says the FDIC
issue is that it can take up to three
months in the end you will get up to 250
000 back but how will you live in the
meantime
now stop that stuff
lukuba says this feels like government
beginning to take over Banks so they can
start cutting people off who don't toe
the line no that was probably a long
time ago to be completely honest yeah I
mean 2008 was way worse but we'll see
we'll see the second and third biggest
collapses happening back to back is kind
of worrying
Sean Ryan says Credit Suisse is next to
fall Global Market next you want to look
that up yeah
they've been troubled a long time yeah
that's scary whoa
Sim Byrne says Phil I remember your Halo
3 Myspace multiplayer video of 15-0
you're still a Halo Legend before
anything else to me remember reach and
OG Bungie oh God I love Halo I love Halo
you ever play Destiny I play I literally
was playing Destiny right before I left
to come here oh really oh yeah light
falls the door that came out yeah really
I just I played it when it first came
out I played it all through uh until
what was what was the last one I played
the the one where the darkness finally
got really okay yeah which one was that
uh that was no I don't I don't remember
what it was called but there were they
that was after they started doing the
seasons and stuff yeah I was the last
one I played yeah I I think it's still
worth worth your time I mean it does get
a little too grindy
constantly doing the uh the
Daily Grind and stuff like that but
Destiny I like Destiny one better
because the PVP was all slide shotguns
you would just slide and then boom
shotgun and you you'd take them out and
then in Destiny 2 they're like we're
gonna like nerfed it yeah Nerf the
shotguns and make it more about your
primary and then it's like let's just
play OverWatch now there's and you can
carry have three guns and apparently the
other one you could only have two or
something like that well you could
always have three I never yeah it
doesn't need one light special on it and
it didn't make sense in part one why
something was special and why something
was primary but now they've kind of
figured that out yeah and now heavy
weapon ammo and stuff I don't know I
haven't played part two in a while but
you know Destiny was a really good game
it sucks because in the beginning there
were fun things people discovered and
they got rid of it all like used to be
able to go through walls using the
sparrow really yeah and there was there
were there were there were parts of the
of the game World they had made that
they didn't open and we would go into
these discontinued areas that like
didn't get released and it was fun and
then they would warn you like we will
ban your account if you keep doing this
and I was like do it then you don't get
my money I don't care but you get
another one it was fun now you can't do
it anymore it's a bummer I couldn't
confirm anything about Credit Suisse
except that it's uh shares it at
all-time low
as of like 15 hours ago hillbillary
Clinton says Tim start your own bank I
already gave you a ton of a ton of my
money because I'm trying to fund the Tim
fire I really do appreciate that I think
maybe uh Jeremy boring needs to create
his own bank the daily the the banking
wire that's a good name the banking wire
like it's a good name you know what I
mean the banking wire uh or Jeremy's
bank I guess I gotta be honest if if
Jeremy boring started a bank right now I
would immediately move all of our
corporate stuff right into it I don't
know that he could John rich is though
so I should definitely we should
definitely look into that
one thing I'm really interested in
though is all local stuff so there are
some local banks that are just West
Virginia banks that I'm really
interested in and we we are working with
one I would much rather see all of the
money here's what I'm saying when y'all
give money to timcast.com as a member
that money doesn't just like go into
Pockets it gets spent in West Virginia
and Maga country it means that the
people who live out here are going to
the grocery store where there's a guy
with a little Trump flag and they're
handing him the ten dollars for the pack
of beer that guy now has money to buy
other things basically you it is it is I
I want to build up local economy out
here where the people are better and I
mentioned being the casino because I go
there all the time
and a guy asked he's like you from
around here and I'm like no I'm from
Chicago but I live here now and he goes
okay and I was like better people and he
goes yeah and you're like I said you're
not not a laptop Politics the poker
table and I was like if you know what I
mean and he goes I probably do and I was
like I can't say exactly what I mean to
the poker table but I got an American
flag at my house and he's like yup like
we all know exactly what we mean because
there are some weirdo people who don't
like American flags that's like half the
country at this point anyway let's read
some more
all right it's a good one p diddle says
too woke to fail
yep
oh here's a good one Joshua Carlisle
says pbd podcast pulled up FDIC balance
sheet showing they only have enough to
enough to cover 1.26 of the 9.9 trillion
in deposits Countrywide
okay but
svb doesn't have that much so it would
have to be a run on every single Bank
look
all I'm hearing from people is that
they're pulling money up every every
person I've asked every person I've
talked to since we've heard about this
news they go are you pulling your money
out are you gonna are gonna pull your
money out of the bank and I'm like
are you are you asking me this because
you are going to because me I'm not
doing anything like I'll pull out some
cash there's there's no way I can pull
out all the cash and just
but I'm hearing tons of people being
like yep why not pull up the max
and I've also heard from some people
saying they tried to and weren't able
I don't want to name who those people
are but
you know some prominent people the other
reason why I don't think there's any
likelihood of a bank run in in
depression analogies don't work as you
know most people don't use cash I have
almost nothing on me I use credit cards
so your credit card's still going to
work even if you know there's there's a
bank run but you know there's no reason
for Bank Run unless people are rational
can that happen absolutely but we got to
be assuring people don't worry you don't
need to take your money out your bank
money's insured but we again shouldn't
be bailing out the people who've got
huge amounts of money invested in bad
Investments and now we're going to pay
the price to save them did you know that
you can buy a 55 gallon drum of 5.56
ammo
how much does that cost like 10 grand
wait wait wait was that one more time
you can buy a 55 gallon drum of 5.56
where from Brownells Brownells huh just
put a bookmark on that one I'll send you
the link yeah
55 gallon drum of 5.56 green tip don't
let that catch on fire steel core oh man
steel core steel core green tip I don't
know if you want that though I mean
that's I mean what steel I know I get it
green tip through a 20 inch barrel is
gonna Vibe check anybody's Army it's
gonna it's gonna it's gonna it's serious
20 inch barrel with a 5.56 is the
meanest is one of the meanest bullets
you can you're gonna find so anyways I
like 11 and a half inch barrels but
that's just me
go ahead
all right Tim Sprague says I started at
Native homesteading for the modern day
Homesteader to buy and sell products I
started this because you told us to get
out of the city very very cool native
homesteading yeah uh I certainly
recommend it we've got a lot of work
going on at the new uh new property
for the new headquarters and we're
trying to get a bunch of infrastructure
built like internet but the materials
are all in short supply so it's taking
forever it really has been crazy over
the past couple of years but uh I'm
really excited I'm really excited for
the new HQ
all right where are we at Hayden 75 says
is this the Black Swan event that could
cause the collapse no a Black Swan event
is something that can't be seen we have
watched this train barreling down the
tracks in 2007 at least yeah yeah but
the average person doesn't the average
person is like who's Joe Biden and
you're like oh heavens and you can't you
know what do you do man what do we got
here we got another slide yep Black Swan
the Black Swan what does this say well
it doesn't say it's an unforeseen event
people warn about black swans the thing
is you cannot compute a probability just
like we cannot compute a probability of
h5n1 naturally mutating into human human
transmission you can't there's no data
to do it we can't compute the
probability of you know that's why it's
artificial intelligence leading to a
collapse there's no data for it so you
can't compute probabilities but you can
foresee these things happens there's
usually experts warning about them but
we normally ignore the works and we're
so focused on having statistics and
probability and and assuming it's a
normal distribution that's what Nasim
Talib wrote about in the Black Swan that
were suckers for Black Swan events so we
need to pay attention to the warnings
don't try to calculate a probability of
an unforeseen event it hasn't happened
before you can't calculate a probability
so you need to be watching out for him
and if you watch out for a Black Swan
you can be prepared for it and you can
survive if it's a collapse or you can
make money as Nasim Talib does as an
investor how much of like the h5n1 is
hysteria because I I just got the last
three years of people telling me covet
was going to kill me and it's like I'm
so burnt out on that they're completely
different covid-19 from day one there's
a Harvard Medical in our in our Fortress
newsletter when it first came out we
said this is not the collapse from a
pandemic we've been working on this is
not it because there was a Harvard
medical studies early out saying The
lethality of this is way below one
percent way below one percent you don't
need to worry about it it's not going to
stop people from going to work unless
the government makes you do it it's not
going to cause a collapse this is 60
percent lethal with h5n1 amongst humans
now when the virus mutates that could
change but even it doesn't need to be
anything double-digit is what we say
that's going to stop you from going to
work because policemen for example if
there's a even a low 20 percent
probability avian flu variant if you go
to work it's not just a 20 chance you'll
die it's a chance you're going to bring
that virus home now if you've got a
couple kids one of them will die of the
60 of people that die 99.99 are obese or
something like that no it's just that's
the total count we haven't had many
human human fatalities from avian flu so
it's a complete census of the deaths and
it's a 60 lethality rate now it could be
a little bit lower if they've completely
missed some cases his point about police
officers and stuff like that is
extremely important like people think
that people forget that
the whatever the situation is that's
going on that's causing civil unrest
if it's bad enough where cops decide I'm
staying home to protect my family that's
the line where where like everything
just Falls to right like so you can
have Society kind of limping along if
you have people that are still going out
and trying to keep Society functioning
properly once people start saying no I'm
not going to do my job and you're
talking about the infrastructure jobs
like police fire Etc and EMS once those
people decide I'm staying home to
protect my family that's when all bets
are off that's when everything falls
apart or if there's too many people
looting and creating violence at once if
a lot of you know you saw that in
Portland if they're even if the police
are out if there's a lot of people
causing violence you can't you can't
stop it there's just too many people to
stop yeah
so let's read some more Super chats
all right what do we got here Jesse B
says the irony is if the diversity
manager had Diversified their funds they
wouldn't have been hit so hard
I was just uh checking my messages
there's a new prageru video outfit oh I
saw it yeah you should check that out I
think it's on their YouTube I need to
check I just saw the message but uh yeah
I filmed with them and we talked about
fake news and I think something else it
was great your question how many times
does someone have to lie to you before
you consider them a liar yeah once
we worked together on put it together I
gave them a bunch of bullet points and
ideas they wrote up like a bunch of they
like framed it out for their other video
style and then I came back and then you
know we went back and forth on writing
out a script it was really really cool
then I sat in a weird room and there was
a big screen screen behind me and then I
said a bunch of words
from a teleprompter it was fun it was
really good though
yep all right number one American Rob
says Tim you convinced me that West
Virginia is a good spot to ride out the
downfall I'm a maintenance guy
sustainable Gardener and have experience
in Live Events plus more do you have any
jobs open for a guy like me yes email
jobs at I think it's jobs at timcast.com
and uh
we will I'll write down your name we
have a job opening too in West Virginia
we're looking for a ranch manager so if
you've got military or law enforcement
officer experience and especially if you
also have some construction skills
because we do a lot of building uh just
go to our website 14ranch.com email me
manager 14ranch.com or hiring in West
Virginia also Tennessee is looking for a
ranch manager too we're opening a new
location there and then New York is
coming New York we're opening more
franchise locations New York not New
York City right well out of New York
City a couple hours outside to the north
and a little bit West we'll be opening
New York there so if you've got a really
great prepper facility or an RV park and
you're interested in joining the fortune
Ranch system we're expanding Now by
franchising and it's a great way for you
to help get help with your sales and
operations and everything else right on
I also do think West Virginia is a great
place the land is inexpensive it's very
close to a bunch of major Urban centers
couple hours drive depending on where
you're at and it's an app it's an
opportunity to grow an economy around
people who there are they're good people
and I have to wonder why that is why it
is that I can go out into West Virginia
and be more likely to meet someone who
knows a little bit about politics than
New York City in New York City they'll
believe fake things
in West Virginia they will believe
correct things not not everybody not
completely I'm saying things like Donald
Trump you go to New York they're like
Donald Trump praised neo-nazis you come
out here and they're like yeah no he
didn't I watched that video I'm like
there's a tendency among people out here
it's good people you know West Virginia
has one of the highest rates of military
membership per capita you want to guess
what area has the worst rate of military
participation
the District of Columbia is
not surprising yep yep yep all right
here we go
ligamouth again says as a doctor I
understand the rationale for gain of
function research and I support it it
should be done on a sinkable floating
platform in the ocean hermetically
sealed from the outside with a skeleton
crew of workers who live there not in a
huge City like Wuhan
right or like on top of a mountain
they do it's uh um bsl4 biosecurity
level four and that's supposed to be
like the best security there's four
layers but it's like come on man
someone gets bitten by a bat and then
they leave and there you go
all right where are we at
what do we got here Group B says Tim you
often say history Rhymes bear Stearns
failed in March of 08 and by September
Lehman Brothers collapsed ushering the
financial crisis will we see something
similar to that later this summer
I don't know I don't think that the
people that own the biggest banks would
be sad if there's another bank
consolidation so don't write that one
off yep I mean it is it is different
it's like previously we're talking about
um value that wasn't there you know when
we're talking about uh these uh what's
the word subprime mortgages it's not the
same situation it was in the past it's
different there's different problems
it's not going to be the same as 08 we
have we have to see frankly none of us
know what's going to happen so yep Jared
Hogan says so Tim are going to bring
back free chat like you said yes so two
issues first was we get a lot of people
complaining that there's no live chat
for the show because it was just flooded
moving too quickly and when people say
they couldn't even read it and move too
fast so then we were like let's do
subscriber only chat and then with
subscriber only chat it mitigated some
of the problem but still move too
quickly eventually we're like let's do
time gated subscriber only chat you can
only post every x amount of seconds
still didn't work still got spam too
many people still got people saying I
wish we could chat during the show so I
said let's do members only chat the
problem then is now you've got
timcast.com membership and YouTube
membership and we don't really care
about YouTube membership we just needed
a way to create a chat that people could
actually read so then someone gave us
the idea of doing a Discord which then
combines timcast.com with the chat so
it's actually cheaper for you better for
us brings the free chat back solves a
lot of the problems the challenge
however is
really easy to get banned from so that
means we have to work out a system that
makes sense so the idea is if you're a
member at timcast.com moment you sign up
you get access to the timcast lounge in
the in our Discord server and there's
going to be rules the purpose of the
Discord server is for having
conversations around the news stories
we're covering and we try to keep the
vibe in there similar to the show
meaning
don't come into the Discord just to be
mean
come in with a real argument and a
concern
and if your concerned as an ideology or
a lifestyle make your make your approach
argumentative and academic instead of
just calling someone names because we
don't we don't want that that's not
that's not the level of conversation we
want to have
then after six months of being a member
at timcast.com you instantly upgrade to
the VIP lounge where you can go into
voice chat and we use voice chat for
Collins on the show or if you sign up at
timcast.com for 25 bucks you go into the
VIP lounge we wanted to make sure that
there was a way to gate out people who
would exploit the system and and harass
and cause problems but we didn't want to
make it pay oriented because then some
people wouldn't be able to get in so if
they were like time or pay I said why
not both so some people can pay some
people can just wait and that's probably
the best way to do it
and then I think you know obviously if
like you're a 25 member for 10 months
then you just downgrade back to 10 or
whatever and you're in the you're in the
VIP lounge anyway so you can just sort
of pass the gate or whatever I don't
know we're trying to figure it out man
there's no simple answers obviously I
wish everything could be free and we
could make money in other ways but it's
just not possible we're not communes
we're capitalists all right where are we
at let's get some let's grab a couple
more
TN says second time I'm super chatting
this look up operation hardtack low
yield nuke delivered by balloon at 85
000 feet it was a test for EMP effects
China sent a balloon to test the jet
stream and our response
we talked about that before I think I'm
pretty sure it was in 1958. send a
balloon over the EMP
Tony ties has great guest tonight Tim no
I certainly think so there you go all
right let's grab a couple more here we
go sanayo charismae says Tim I work with
U.S Bank think it's a good idea to
withdraw some funds before it hits them
yeah I have no idea I'm not a financial
guy I can't give any advice I can only
tell you that
um I don't think people going on TV and
saying everything is fine is going to
convince anybody after 2008 and
I mean that's a challenge you go on a
show like this and say the Enders and I
get your money and then you cause the
collapse yeah you come on the show and
lie everything's fine and just like
who's gonna believe you so the real
answer is look man you make a decision
for yourself I ain't gonna tell you what
to do I'll tell you what I'll do you
know we'll move out of cities get some
chickens get some emergency food because
if in the end nothing happens I got some
food and I got some chickens sounds like
a good life
and then if it really is the worst case
scenario and the collapse happens I am
thankful I have food and chickens that's
just me
all right what do we get what do we get
my nipple says microtransactions are
great more paywalls
well we're trying to reduce the paywall
we're trying to we'll have the free chat
on YouTube and then the Discord chat for
members that way I I this this works we
want to create more things that members
get so that your 10 bucks goes further
instead of just the uncensored show so
you'll get both you'll get both how
about that work how about that all right
that's a hot take all right Fire Sky
says what about gilded if Discord
doesn't work out I guess that's uh
roadblocks or something yeah yielded as
a Roblox so it's probably we were told
it was worse yeah potentially all right
last one Daniel says I know Discord chat
is already in development but would it
be possible to use gilded instead pretty
much the same thing from my limited look
but we heard that the censorship is
actually worse all right everybody but
we're getting to it and uh we will
hopefully have it set up so smash that
like button if you have not already
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends because that is
the most powerful way that podcasts
actually succeed and grow is word of
mouth and also become a member at
timcast.com to help us keep the lights
on keep doing the work we do
it's an interesting business model we
have you get the show for free fine and
then we hope that some people like the
show not that they're going to pay 10
bucks a month for the after show and
that funds everything but if at any
point that doesn't work I don't know I
don't know what we do the model seems to
be working for now but with ad rates
dropping it's like we're trying to find
other ways to generate Revenue to keep
the company growing expanding because I
want to win a culture War so we got the
coffee shop we got a bunch of stuff
we're working on so the live uncensored
show will be up in about 10 minutes
check that out at timcast.com members
only you can follow the show at timcast
IRL you can follow me personally at
timcast Drew do you want to shout
anything out again we just appreciate
your interest in fortitude ranch we're
looking for ranch managers in some areas
we're expanding with franchising and if
you don't do photo Ranch that's fine but
do get your weapon as you've been
advised and be prepared because uh
collapse could happen tomorrow not just
from h5n1 our Electric System but almost
any cause it happens historically it's
going to happen to us and we're a lot
more vulnerable now than we've been in
the past right on I am Phil that remains
on Twitter I am Phil that remains
official on Instagram uh give me a
follow and I'm Ian cross on fallmedian
crossland.net anywhere on social media
at Ian Crossland Drew thanks
fortituderanch.com is where people can
go to find you and then also if this
documentary grid down power up I'm
looking forward to looking at something
thanks for coming man thanks
I search uh I am at surge.com if you
want to complain about audio please
argue with me on Twitter bring it on I
know more than you talk to you there all
right everybody we will see you all over
at timcast.com in a few minutes thanks
for hanging out